in seinen filmen ist peter lerch die
immer bis zum äußersten gegangen bis zu
den äußersten fragen des frack barren
bis an den rand dessen was bilder sagen
können
für diese lust am experimentieren hat er
früh einen seelenverwandten in dem
konzept künstler roman signer gefunden
über den er 1995 seinen ersten kinofilm
dreht beide künstler teilen das
interesse an den höllischen abgründen
besonders deren explosiven teile und
ihrer experimentellen darstellung
der kameramann peter broja war in den
letzten zehn jahren das auge peter
liechtis und sein freund mit dem pace of
finnish extrem wird sich im extrem um
hier grüßt zusammen und das ist für mich
dass ich extrem die extremste
herausforderung der sound of insects
radikale fragen an das leben und
radikale bildsprache legt die und goya
folgen der geschichte eines mannes der
einen wald zog um hungers zu sterben wie
der held der literarischen vorlage
bauten sie aus plastikplanen eine hütte
und gebildeten mit der kamera das
tagebuch des sterbenden immer am rand
dessen was bilder ausdrücken können sie
nun zwanzigster september ich muss einen
brief an die einreisebehörde der anderen
welt schreiben
meine seele beabsichtigt in zwei oder
drei tagen einzutreffen
bitte nehmen sie sie freundlich auf
peter ihrig die durchlebte und durchlitt
ein thema das war seine art des
filmemachens muss im film
und das ist therapie wird sicher
verklebt die sein letzter und vielleicht
intimster film geht weit zurück erzählt
von ihm und seinen eltern wieder stellt
sich die die ganz radikalen fragen
doch diesmal mit einem neuen kunstgriff
er selbst tritt als kasper auf seine
eltern betreten dann eben auch als hasen
die bühne von vaters garten am anfang
war ich eifersüchtig auf den garten war
immer allein
das waren es die kollegen und danach kam
der garten wieder wenn ich da nur der
garten immer der garten
ich fühle mich wohl so
ich bin nicht pingelig
ich habe einfach gerne ordnung die
mutter flüchtet sich in ihren glauben
zwischen der pedanterie des vaters und
der bigotterie der mutter ein
verzweifelter kaspar peter liechti peter
liechti erspart weder sich noch mutter
und schwester die frage ob er denn auch
platz in ihrem paradies hätte
dieser berührende film ist nun sein
vermächtnis geworden
eine rätsel denkbarer wies auch auf und
sie in worte vielleicht doch noch grün
statt
dennis mitchell mit dem betrag